I heard today I don't know if it's true
that Woody Harrelson was sort of pushing
for you to play this character whose
opposite him in the film because he
liked the fact that you were mostly
vegan and for a specific reason what was
the other thing way to get a wrong yeah
what was that reason well I mean he just
didn't you know there's there's scenes
were there's proximity don't give
anything away and so he would come in
and he just is that guy who comes in to
set like to the trailer and you know
kind of shaves and puts aloe vera on his
face and that's it it's kind of crazy
well make it nothing so he'd come over
and every once in a while like you know
if we had if I kissed him or something
he'd be like Burt's Bees he doesn't I
mean but it's across the board
we're not using wd-40 we're using
coconut oil like he really it's no
plastic on the set like it's really
about just keeping that toxicity out and
and this industry can be a huge polluter
and I thought everyone I think actually
really appreciated it so he likes
probably also the fact that if you do
have a kissing scene you haven't just
been eating a chili dog
yeah just like ribs like hold my rib you
know right yeah